i think it's
kind of fascinating if you look
throughout history and race is just part
of that
is uh we create the other
and uh treat the other with disdain
through the legal system but just
through human nature i tend to believe
we mentioned
offline that i work with uh robots
it sounds absurd to say especially to
you especially because we're talking
about racism and it's so prevalent today
i do believe that there will be
almost like a civil rights movement for
robots
because uh with the i think there's a
huge
value to society of having
artificial intelligence systems uh that
are uh that interact with humans that
are and
are human-like and the more they become
human-like
you will they will start they will start
to ask very fundamentally human
questions about
freedom about suffering about justice
and they will will have to come face to
face like look in the mirror
and asking the question just because
we're biologically based just because
we're
sort of uh well just because we're human
does that mean we're the only ones that
deserve the rights
again giving forming another
other group which is robots and i'm sure
there could be
along that path different
versions of other that we form so racism
race is certainly a big other that we've
made
as you said a lot of progress on
throughout the history of this country
but it does feel like we always create
as we make progress
create new other groups and of course
the other
the other group that uh perhaps is
outside the legal system that people
talk about
is the essential now i eat a lot of meat
but the torture of animals you know the
people talk about when we look back from
you know a couple centuries from now
look back at the kind of things we're
doing to animals
we might regret that we might see that
in a very different light and it's kind
of interesting to see the future
trajectory of
what we wake up to about the injustice
in our
in our ways um but the robot one is the
one i'm
especially focused on because uh but at
this moment in time it seems ridiculous
but i'm sure most civil rights movements
throughout history seem ridiculous at
first
well it's interesting sort of out
outside of my uh
intellectual bailiwick uh robots as
i understand the development of
um artificial intelligence uh though
the um the aspect
that uh
still is missing is this notion of of
consciousness
uh and that it's it's consciousness
that is the the thing that uh
will uh will move um
if it were to exist and i'm not saying
that it can or will
but if it were to exist would move
robots
from uh machines to
something different that ex
something that experienced the world in
a way analogous to
what how we experience it um
and also as i understand the science
there's a um
unlike what you see on on television
that we're not
we're not uh there yet in terms of uh
this notion of uh the machines having
uh a consciousness um uh
or a great general intelligence all
those kinds of things
yeah yeah a huge amount of progress has
been made and
there is it's fascinating to watch so
i'm on both minds as a person who's
building them
i'm realizing how sort of quote-unquote
dumb they are
but also looking at human history and
how
poor we are predicting the progress of
innovation and technology
it's obviously that we have to be humble
by our ability to predict coupled with
the fact that we
keep uh to use terminology carefully
here
we keep discriminating against the
intelligence of
uh artificial systems the smarter they
get
the more ways we find to dismiss the
their intelligence
so this this has just been going on
throughout where
i it's almost as if we're threatened
in the most primitive human way
animalistic way we're threatened by the
power of
other creatures and we want to lessen
dismiss them
so consciousness is a really important
one but the one i think about a lot
in terms of consciousness the very
engineering question
is whether the display of consciousness
is the same
as the possession of consciousness so
if a robot tells you they are conscious
if a robot looks like they're suffering
when you torture them if a robot is
afraid of death
and says they're afraid of death and are
legitimately afraid like
for in terms of just uh everything we as
humans
use to determine the ability of somebody
to be their own
entity they're the one that loves one
that fears
one that hopes one that can suffer
if if the robot like in the dumbest of
ways
is able to display that we
it changes it starts changing things
very quickly
i'm not sure what it is but it does seem
that there's a huge component to
consciousness
that is a social creation like we
together
create our consciousness like we believe
our common humanity
together alone we wouldn't be aware of
our humanity
and the law as it protects our freedoms
seems to
be a construct of the social construct
and when you add
other creatures into it it's not obvious
to me that like you have to
build there will be a moment when you
say
this thing is now conscious i think
there's going to be
a lot of fake it until you make it and
there'll be a very gray area between
fake and make that is going to force us
to contend
with what it means to be an entity that
deserves rights
where all men are created equal the the
men part
might have to expand in ways that we
are not yet anticipating that's very
interesting i mean my favorite
the fundamental thing i love about
artificial intelligence is it gets
smarter and smarter it challenges to
think of
uh what is right the questions of
justice questions of freedom
it basically challenges us
to uh to understand our own mind
to understand uh what uh like
almost from an engineering first
principles perspective to understand
what it is that makes us human
that is at the core of all the rights
that we talk about and all the documents
we write
so even if we don't give rights
artificial intelligence systems we may
be able to construct
more fair legal systems to protect us
humans
well i mean interesting ontological
question uh
between the the performance of
consciousness and
and and actual consciousness to the
extent
that it's um that actual consciousness
is
anything beyond some contingent reality
uh but you've posed a number of of
interesting philosophical questions and
then
there's also it strikes me that
that um philosophers of religion would
pose another set of questions
uh as well when you um deal with uh
issues of uh of structure versus soul
body versus soul and
and uh it it would be a
it will be a complicated mix and i
suspect i'll be
uh dust by the time those questions get
get worked out
and uh so yeah the soul the soul is a
fun one
there's no soul i'm i'm not sure maybe
you can correct me but
there's very few discussion of soul in
our legal system right
right correct so uh but there is a
discussion about what constitutes a
human
being and i mean you gestured at the
notion of
uh the potential of the law uh widening
the domain of uh so of of human being so
and and in that sense right uh you know
people are very angry because they can't
uh
uh get uh sort of pain and suffering
damages
if someone negligently kills a pet
because a pet is not
a human being and people say well i love
my
pet but the law sees uh a pet as
chattel as property like this this water
bottle
uh so the the current legal definitions
um trade on a definition of
humanity that may not be worked out in
any sophisticated way but
certainly um there's a there's a
share broad and shared understanding of
what what it what it means
so probably doesn't uh explicitly
contain a definition of something like
soul uh but it's it's more robust than
you know a carbon-based organism that
there's something
a little more distinct about what the
law
thinks a human being is
you